hello good afternoon I'm an okra Farooqi
I'm an associate professor
Boulevard I'm also an alum of Yale
College class of 94
so I wanted to welcome you all here on
campus and today I'm going to be
speaking I should say I'm a painter
that's what I do primarily so I'm not an
art historian so I'm going to be talking
about Josef Albers interaction of color
from my perspective it's very loud
outside but I would get off I'll gather
my composure in the courses he taught
Josef Albers provided students primarily
with experiences could we also get the
lights lower too
okay so in the courses he taught Josef
Albers provided his students primarily
with experiences before he taught them
rules he prompted them to actually see
color once they had demonstrated that
they were seeing only then would he
introduced them to the systems of color
theory and or pigment mixing by
compiling the answers to his masterful
classroom assignments in the volume
interaction of color Albers provides
each of us with that with these
experiences and you Albers approach to
teaching originated in the Bauhaus an
avant-garde art school in Germany where
Albert's both studied and taught the
Bauhaus disavowed the hierarchy between
applied and fine art with an
experimental material and hands-on
curriculum with its closure under Nazi
pressure in 1933 many of the Bauhaus
artists fled Germany and Albers via
Black Mountain College eventually became
chair of the design department at Yale
after his retirement he worked with the
Yale Press in 1963 to publish the
interaction of color as a screen printed
edition of 150 color plates one of these
original volumes is laid out here for
you to look at after my talk I hope
you'll have a chance i time the talk so
it was a little shorter so that you'll
have a chance to look at these beautiful
impeccably printed plates from the 1963
edition in talking about the interaction
of color Albers says this book does not
follow an academic conception of theory
and practice it reverses this order in
places practice over Theory which after
all is the conclusion of practice Albers
didn't want to tell his students the
right answer that would prevent them
from finding the answer themselves
and Albers teaching methods are
ingeniously congruent with how color
functions in experience Albert says in
dealing with color illusion or color
relativity it is practical to
distinguish factual facts from actual
facts this is the distinction that
Albers makes between physical fact and
psychic effect factual color is how we
name measure or locate color what we
know color to be in isolation I've
pasted here a color chart based on the
Munsell color system used by a printing
company to locate quantify and map color
actual color on the other hand refers to
how color appears to us when it exists
in a context as it inevitably does in
the world as we experience it thus it
could be said that factual color is
rural based it is what a color is as a
fixed absolute and isolated entity by
contrast we learn about actual color via
trial and error it is fluid contingent
and integrated factual color has always
been the focus of most of historical
color theory in art design industry and
science for example theorists of color
have created color spaces or color
shapes or color solids from which to
locate and quantify every imaginable
color here is Phillipe autorun jizz
color sphere from 1810 showing both the
surface of the sphere as well as
vertical cross-sections and horizontal
cross-sections this is a diagram of
Albert moon cells color sphere which was
established in 1900 and still is in use
today in various industries the moon
cells fear uses the three properties of
color hue value and saturation as
different axes of the sphere
and finally we have the CIE chromaticity
chart developed in 1931 a triangular
color space that deals with the color of
light it established RGB color space
that is now used for screen color each
end of the triangle is one of the three
primary colors of light red green and
blue and colors are located as
percentages of these three colors
so while factual color has been fairly
entrenched in color theory ironically
it's also how we how most of us think
about color on a daily basis in our
everyday lives we delude ourselves and
believe in color only as fact my hair is
black that shirt is green actual color
on the other hand has been the realm of
philosophers most notably Goethe and
Vidkun Stein artists teachers and many
others but Albers was the one who
systematically demonstrated colors
elasticity so what I'm going to do now
is switch to okay I just have to make
sure that the iPad understands what I
need to be vertical alright that worked
thank you um I'm gonna switch to the
iPad app go to the home page okay the
Yale press recently published an iPad
app of the interaction of color because
the original volume was large heavy and
relatively expensive book it ultimately
ended up in rare book collections its
status elevated to that of a precious
art object but albers intent was that
the book should be a handbook a working
document of sorts for artists and
teachers
fifty years after the initial
publication of interaction of color this
app can more thoroughly fulfill Albers
intent of accessibility so the iPad app
allows us to view all the plates and
commentary and just to reiterate the
interaction of color as I mentioned
earlier is a compilation of students
answers to Albers problems so these were
works done by his students and he would
give them problems to solve and they
would do so by making collages with cut
paper so the first problem that Albers
would give his students is make one
color look like two there are two
squares here one at top and one at
bottom they actually look quite
different but the app allows me to
expose that they are factually the same
so if I click on this button here the
flap lifts by clicking this button the
middle portion of the study lifts off to
show that the two squares are really the
ends of one consistently colored strip
of paper in the original screen printed
edition these are carefully constructed
paper flaps when we look at the study
students will often ask me how does this
happen
we know that orange and blue are
opposite each other on the color wheel
they're what we call complementary
colors seeing one color makes our I want
to compensate by seeing its complement
therefore when the end of this brown
orange strip of paper is next to a blue
background on the top part of the study
it appears to be a brighter orange when
the other end of the strip is next to a
bright orange
it appears bluer thus making it look
browner and duller
in color there are three components of
play in addition to hue value and
saturation are always at work value is
what Albers calls light intensity it is
how light or dark a color is in relation
to our idea of a grayscale just as hue
operates and contacts so does value see
here there are two great wry angles the
top triangle looks much darker than the
bottom triangle but when we remove the
middle gradient we see that both
triangles are the same middle gray again
in Albers original edition we could
isolate the triangles by using paper
masks so when the triangle on top is
placed next to the light part of the
gradient it appears a darker and
vice-versa
so this problem would be called three
colors appear as two oh sorry I've got
the wrong one this one is three colors
appears to here that that would be the
problem that Albers would give his
student make three colors look like two
so when you look at this it looks like
they're figures and grounds are reversed
meaning that there would be only two
colors present but we learn by looking
at the right-hand side of the plate that
that X's which are the figures are
connected showing that they are one
continuous line of color so there are
actually three colors here two
background colors and one color for the
figure the color of the X's represents
the middle mixture of the two colors
it's an incredibly elastic color in
between Cult yellow and purple and seems
to be on top purple and on the bottom
yellow purple and yellow are
complementary colors and while we know
that color is relative it is surprising
to see one color stretch so much as to
become its opposite
okay so this problem is called two
colors look like one
so here Albers asked his students to
focus now on the dividing line between
the two backgrounds so if you could just
focus on the dividing line between the
two backgrounds it's more convincing
that the center squares are the same
color they look to be the same color the
more you stare at the center line but in
this instance the center squares are not
the same color they are quite different
colors which the mask allows me to see
the other thing that the app allows you
to do is to actually move so it's as if
though you're working on the collage and
you haven't glued it down yet so you can
compare and there's another flap here
that's based on the original folio where
you can see the blue of the ones bottom
square placed on top and the pink of the
top square placed on bottom so this on
the top part of the study a dollar less
saturated pink sits on a much more
saturated or more chromatically intense
pink the saturated pink in a sense
overwhelms the dull middle square and
makes it appear more like blue so it's
pushing it to the other side of the
color wheel the same thing is happening
at the bottom where a more saturated
blue makes the dollar blue look Pinker
this is what Albers calls color
subtraction a more saturated color will
subtract saturation from the less
saturated sister color so here you see a
red circle please stare steadily at the
center of the red circle it may be
difficult for your eyes to keep fixed on
that point but humor me and try to keep
your gaze steady I know many of you have
done this exercise before in various
contexts perhaps in elementary school
even but I can't resist
repeating it now whenever there's a
group of people together it's fun to
perform this trick but its success
depends on your study gaze toward the
center of the circle despite what might
be occurring along the edges of the
figure continue to stare at the center
of the circle so what did you see
hopefully many of you stared at the
center of the circle and saw an after
image which was a Bluegreen after image
or cyan which is the complement of red
so again these colors green and red or
cyan and red exist opposite each other
in the color wheel and this is called an
after image also known as simultaneous
contrast as I mentioned earlier this is
how the human eye works when we stare at
red our eye exact exhausts our capacity
to see red and compensates by seeing the
opposite color this simultaneous
contrast explains most of color
deception when we see we are seeing
after images all of the time so I often
tell my students the story of working on
a class architecture project as an
undergraduate the project involved many
days and hours of cutting bright red
orange paper when I was finally done I
breathed a sigh of relief only to be
horrified at the sight of my blue and
cold complexion in the mirror for many
for some time afterward everything and
everyone around me had been sucked of
its characteristic warmth it was
actually quite freaky but it was after
image at work Alber says quote the fact
that after image or simultaneous
contract contrast is a psycho
physiological phenomenon should prove
that no normal eye not even the most
trained one is foolproof against color
too
exception he who claims to see colors
independent of their illusory changes
fools only himself and no one else so
the plates also show how we can find the
middle mixture between two colors and
create an illusion of transparency even
when all the colour is present are
opaque we can use that illusion to
create spatial illusions in colour in
this case the more dominant the yellow
is over the red the more it advances in
space
album Albers also addresses optical
color mixture which is a different type
of color illusion than an after image
when the bits of color are small enough
and that's close enough together our I
will optically mix the two or more
colors in this instance two brick walls
are made of the same red but the black
mortar makes the overall picture seem
darker while the white mortar makes the
overall picture seem lighter the bezel
defect is a certain type of optical
mixture named after ville hi Yvonne
build a run rug designer who noticed
that when he changed one color thread in
his rug designs the entire design would
change but optical mixture has been used
for centuries in mosaics tapestries more
recently an impressionist painting and
pointillism in Albers time as the photo
mechanical printing process such as
halftone reproductions in newspapers
where greyscale is created by using only
varying proportions of black dots on a
white ground and in our time optical
mixture exists on every digital print
and computer screen or projection we
look at including this one the pixels
the ultimate use of optical mixture with
bits so tiny we cannot even recognize
them as such
so the images I've shown thus far are
the more pared down and instructional
images in the Albers folio and Albers
admits that quote these studies permit
hardly any self expression end quote
but there are many other studies in the
folio that are quite complicated and
dynamic many of these can be found in
the free study section so here's some
examples of the free studies in addition
to performing the systematic systematic
exercises Albers students also made
independent works the systematic studies
occupied most of the in-class time while
the free studies were done his homework
throughout the Albers course
there are numerous beautiful plates in
this volume and the I paddle app app
allows you to see all of them in the
most immediate way in a more immediate
way than I've ever experienced the app
also allows you not only to view the
plates but to rework the studies
themselves and anybody can do this no
matter what your background in art or
color this is how you can learn to see
color by trial and error and by doing
the exercises so if you go to you can go
to my studies and all of the plates
appear as blanks so this was a study
that I did based off of the format of
one of the outburst uh DS but I added my
own colors so you can basically choose a
palette and pull these things out and
change just with the touch of a finger
of the colors so it's like working with
cut paper all of the Albers exercises
were done with cut paper because Albers
didn't want his students to get bogged
down with mixing pigments and being
distracted by that he wanted the process
to be about seeing so the app in some
way even augments that further by
allowing you access to an Eva even wider
range of of colors at your fingertips
okay so now that you've seen some of the
plates from the Albers volume I want to
kind of continue my presentation with a
broader question which is what makes
Albers so continually influential and
still relevant to our present moment so
we might turn to other thinkers and
artists who are kindred spirits of
Albers to answer this question or to
consider it I speak less about direct
influence and more about shared
perceptual and cultural experiences
that yields to more interest methods and
conclusions
so Albers idea of putting practice
before theory was not in itself
groundbreaking in remarks on color
Ludwig Wittgenstein says quote to
describe the game of tennis is not to
teach it to him and vice-versa
here Vidkun stein reflects on
philosopher and mathematician Bertrand
Russell's two types of knowledge
knowledge by description and knowledge
by acquaintance in relation to color
knowledge by description is being able
to describe the rules of language for
instance or tennis or mathematics while
knowledge by acquaintance is being able
to perform the rules of those things via
experience and this is how we actually
learn language we don't learn language
by diagramming sentences we learn
language by singing language as an
infant in a very experience away and so
Albers teaches color by acquaintance and
certainly painters and scientists knew
about simultaneous contrast after images
an optical mixture for many years before
Albers for example Edgar Degas says
painting is the ability to surround a
Venetian red so it looks like a
Vermillion a Venetian red is a dull red
and vermilion is a brilliant saturated
red
so for daga painting is not about
putting down the bright saturated color
but about creating a set of context so
that the dull color may appear bright
it's something that painters have used
in their work as they move paint from
the palette to the context of the
painting the color inevitably changes
before them painters call this factual
color in isolation local color and have
long understood the limitations of
painting with only local color in mind
another aspect of color that Albers only
touches upon in the interaction of color
is that in addition to colors optical
instability color changes according to
lighting conditions there is lie
that is warm light that is cool harsh
light that emphasizes contrast low light
that diminishes it so this is something
that has occupied painters such as Monet
who painted the cathedral at Rouen
repeatedly during different times the
day as another way of showing us the
fluidity of color and perception so I'm
going to show you some of my recent
paintings so perhaps you'll see what
draws me to the work of Josef Albers for
instance optical color mixing is clearly
a play in my work while you may see pink
here the painting is made up only of
three factual colors red white and dark
green but because the lines are very
fine
the colors mix optically and the white
and red create the illusion of pink on
the surface here's a detail shot a
close-up view of the painting there's
another one that has quite a bit of
optical mixing and viewing the painting
from a great distance the optical mixing
is more convincing as we step closer to
the painting detail shot the factual
colors begin to be revealed ironically I
never took a color class while I was an
undergraduate at Yale though I did often
walk through what was called the Albers
corridor of prints at the Yale art
gallery my own paintings deal very much
with color and I only came to study the
Albers volume after years of painting
when I began to teach in that sense I
learned about color very much how Albers
would want one to learn about color by
seeing color and by using it when I
first started looking at the Albers
folio I was amazed at how clearly it
explicate it and augmented what I
already knew to be true about color but
even though I had worked with color for
many years and had experienced colors
instability firsthand on a regular basis
I still found myself in a slight state
of disbelief at times I even assured
myself that one of the plates was a miss
prynt because I could not believe what I
saw when I lifted the flap perhaps my
temporary experience of disbelief is key
to understanding the importance of the
interaction of color
we know that the reversal of theory and
practice or the understanding of colors
relatively were not in it's in
themselves groundbreaking so what makes
Albers different for one thing Albers
interaction of color was born out of
Albers own teaching its nature is
collaborative and greater than one
person singular vision Albers provided
the questions and the structures though
many today associate the work only with
Albers Albers himself was clear in the
volume that his students were his
collaborators the majority of the plates
are the best example of his students
responses to his questions and exercises
the book itself is the result of
experience of countless hours of
numerous people seeing color but there
is something else here that is
groundbreaking and while the use of
colored paper seems simple and obvious
to us now it provides a key to Albers
success Albers writes color paper
permits a repeated use of precisely the
same color without the slightest change
in tone light or surface quality we can
choose from a large collection of tones
displayed in front of us and can thus
constantly compare neighboring and
contrasting colors this offers a
training which no palette can provide
this method mirrors the concept of the
scientific control and unchanging or
fixed group of colors can be compared to
their variable counterparts the student
had the ability to compare back and
forth between factual and actual color
via colored paper we who view the folio
have the ability to compare factual and
actual via the masks flaps and folds in
the original folio the new iPad app
includes this function and augments it
with movement we can move pieces of
color around on the studies just as the
student could before gluing down the
collage the ability to create these
comparisons is not something one sees in
a painting while I may have the
experience of moving color from pallet
to canvas this remains usually a private
experience the ability for comparison
continues to be central to the
wide-ranging success of the interaction
of color I remember meeting with a
student who said she didn't want to
learn about the rules of color because
that would demystify the experience of
color for her but to me color seemed so
inexhaustible that no matter how much I
study and contain it it surprises and
alludes albers allows us to hold on to
the factual in our minds as a kind of
zero degrees from which to leap even if
we may never really access factual color
it remains a necessary mental framework
and as much as Albers verbally verbally
rejected the rule based color systems
that preceded him he created his very
own effective rules and systems to teach
and deal with color I think it's the
discipline in the face of color that
makes him so successful as a teacher and
so widely accessed outside of the field
people can relate to the rules
although Albers rules make fun of rules
we can also consider Albers relationship
to the philosophers of his day
for example maurice merleau-ponty who
championed the field of philosophy known
as phenomenology asked the question
about where truth resides he used the
example of a tile pattern in a swimming
pool distorted by the light passing
through water he said that most people
see this as an illusion believing that
there is some fixed truth out there
the grid under the swimming pool that is
being distorted by our perception or by
the conditions around the pool like
Albers he notes that this belief is
something of a delusion and he proposes
that we reverse this hierarchy of what
we know over what we see can't we see
the distortions as a valid reality in
fact they were the only valid reality
for merleau-ponty he says when through
the waters thickness I see the tiled
bottom of the pool I do not see it
despite the water and the reflections I
see it through them and because of them
but there is some deeper thing about
Albers project that is always on the tip
of my tongue it's not that interaction
of color demonstrated merleau-ponty x'
ideas visually but that his work also
simultaneously tugs away at it like
staring at red for too long and our eye
compensating with the green while Albers
championed the actual he acknowledges
the factual rather than rejecting fact
or essence as irrelevant he affirms the
necessary role it has to play in our
understanding of contingency ultimately
the terms factual and actual are
codependent we cannot understand the
actual without verifying the factual the
brilliance of Albers is that he used an
acknowledged fact to reverse the
established hierarchy a factual over
actual all of Albers structure serves to
celebrate the contingent and unruly
world of color for a long time
philosophers have debated whether truth
exists in essence or appearance but
Josef Albers volume enacts this quandary
more beautifully than anything I know
thank you
you